I believe that I have a very loud voice
and I'm not ashamed or embarrassed or
shying away from expressing what I
think.
I don't have to like everyone.
My website's called Perez Hilton Dot
Com.
It's not called the New York Times.
I don't have to feign of activity.
I love the entertainment industry.
If I didn't,
I wouldn't still be in it and I wouldn't
have chosen that topic for my website.
When I first started blogging,
when I moved to Los Angeles in 2002,
I wanted to be an actor,
but like nine out of 10 people that
moved to Los Angeles,
it didn't work for me and I'm so
thankful because I'm so much happier now
doing what I do then if I would have
been an actor that was struggling to
work or even if I did get some kind of
success.
I love being my own boss.
I love calling the shots and I love what
I do.
I feel really lucky.
My perspective on fame hasn't changed at
all because I'm still normal.
I'm a normal person and I do normal
things.
I haven't let fame affect me.
Uh,
which sometimes people do,
they can buy into their own hype.
I think the fact that I have an alter
ego helps and I think the fact that for
every two people that like me,
there's probably four point five that
hate me.
That also helps too.
So I don't think that I'm hot shit,
you know,
I don't have a big head.
Well,
I already do have a big head,
but I don't have as big a head as I
could have.